[Music]
clumsy just celebrated his 25th
anniversary
and you know you're talking about
what it was like for you guys early on
honest to god i was never about the
moment maybe it's a fault because i
missed a lot of great moments along the
way i don't know what it sold three
million records a bunch of hits down in
the us and across europe and stuff and
it was just this massive thing for us it
was amazing i didn't get to appreciate
it well
because i was always saying hey this is
great but don't judge us by this one
record
[Music]
spiritual machines 2 is my favorite
album legit it's my favorite body of
work we've ever made although it's a
sequel to their critically acclaimed lp
spiritual machines the latest records
from our lady peace still feels fresh
[Music]
stop making stupid people famous is like
one of my favorite titles of any song
ever and
yeah but the music and the video also
have like that like positive spin it
could have just been really cliche and
typical with that title but the title is
almost clickbait and the song is
supposed to be you know somewhat
aspirational the whole the course is
about working on a dream and rain is
currently working on making his son's
musical dreams a reality i'm literally
in a studio right now making a record
with my oldest son rowan and even where
he's coming from in his music for a 17
year old is phenomenal